هذا مشهد يضاف هو الاخر الى التصعيد
الاحتلال ضد الفلسطينيين هنا في قلب بلده
حزمه شمالي القدس المحتله قوات الاحتلال
خلال الليل وفجر اليوم قامت بهدم العديد
من المنشات هنا احداها في قلب البلده على
الجانب الجنوبي من الشارع الذي يعبر من
قلب بلده حزمه بتعتبر السلطات الاحتلال ان
هذا الجزء من الشارع وتابع لبلديه القدس
لذلك ارسلت جرافاتها وقامت بهدم مثل هذه
المنشئه منشات اخرى في مناطق متفرقه
بذريته انها غير قانونيه من وجهه نظرها
هذه المنشات التي تستخدم بعضها هناك حتى
حظائر اغنام بالاضافه الى ذلك همم ويعتاج
منها العديد بدون قائمه منذ سنوات طويله
قامت بهدمها بعد منتصف الليل دون ان توجه
حتى اختارات بذلك لاصحابها او لسكانها هي
من مشاهد قائمه
بمقابل منازل المواطنين انفسهم وليست هي
طارئه في الفتره الاخيره كانت قبل ان نحو
عام سلطات الاحتلال قد هدمت عده منشات
قريبه من الحاجز العسكري على الشارع
الرئيسي في منطقه قريبه من هنا لكن هذه
المره هي دخلت في قلب بلده حزما وبعضها
موجود في قلب البلده والبعض الاخر على
الشارع الرئيسي